[Musique]
lumos
que pensez-vous que vous faites
bienvenue dans l'héritage de Poudlard
vous êtes un nouvel étudiant à la célèbre école
de sorcellerie et de sorcellerie avec une
capacité unique à manipuler la puissante
magie ancienne cachée dans le monde sorcier
que vous devrez découvrir  qu'y a-t-il derrière le
retour de cette magie oubliée et
qui cherche à l'exploiter pour détruire le
genre sorcier, car vous êtes peut-être celui qui
décide du sort de tout le monde sorcier,
mais avant de pouvoir étudier la magie et commencer
à résoudre ces mystères, vous devez créer
le  sorcière ou sorcier que vous voulez être
lorsque vous arrivez à poudlard vous serez réparti
dans l'une des quatre
maisons de poudlard gryffondor poufsouffle
serdaigle ou serpentard après vous être installé dans votre
dortoir vous rencontrerez vos
colocataires dans la salle commune vous
devrez ensuite  assister aux cours et vous
avez du rattrapage à faire car vous
commenciez à Poudlard tard en cinquième
année, vous êtes donc le nouvel étudiant,
vous commencerez vos études en assistant à
Charms Defe  nse contre les
cours d'herboristerie et de potions des arts sombres, pour n'en nommer que
quelques-uns
travail, mais je suis
convaincu que nous nous attaquerons à un tel défi avec la
passion et la rigueur requises,
la meilleure façon de s'entraîner est de se battre en duel,
nous commencerons par le
temps de youtube pour un bon accueil à Poudlard
matières dangereuses enseignées dans cette école
ici vous rencontrerez vos professeurs et
apprendrez à lancer des sorts cultiver des plantes magiques
brasser des potions et plus entre les cours
vous pourrez explorer le château
célèbre pour ses secrets enchantements et
mystères
vous découvrirez des donjons et  des passages secrets
[Musique
] ainsi que des énigmes difficiles qui
nécessiteront des compétences magiques et un esprit intelligent
pour les résoudre,
vous pourriez même vous retrouver dans des lieux emblématiques que
vous n'avez jamais pu
explorer  avant
[Musique]
nous sommes à la fin des années 1800, alors même si les
salles communes et les cours sont peut-être familiers, la plupart
de vos professeurs ne le seront pas, mais
vous reconnaîtrez peut-être quelques visages
tout en vous amusant une fois que Patrick me
laissera rejoindre la chasse sans tête, j'aurai raison
là avec eux, la souffrance est sûre de les
gagner oh n'oubliez pas pourquoi je suis ici,
vous apprendrez à connaître ce groupe éclectique
de sorcières et de sorciers talentueux en classe
et tout en effectuant des missions sur site
qui font partie d'un programme spécial
ceux conçus  pour vous aider à rattraper
les autres cinquièmes années à votre propre rythme
[Musique] les
opportunités d'aventure abondent dans
la région entourant Poudlard
les capacités magiques que vous apprenez à
maîtriser grâce à vos travaux scolaires seront
bientôt testées alors que vous percez un mystère dangereux
en travaillant aux côtés du
professeur accompli et pourtant énigmatique
fig pour essayer de découvrir si les rumeurs d'
une rébellion croissante des gobelins ont un
poids et si la sécurité de
Poudlard est dans la balance, j'ai une
opinion  les ions diffèrent quant à la menace
qu'il représente vraiment
[Music] les
loyalistes sont capables de bien plus
que les gens ne réalisent que le monde sorcier
de cette époque est semé d'embûches
créatures corrompues par une force magique
puissants gobelins
et sinistres sorcières et sorciers tous
prêts à  se battre même tuer pour atteindre
ses propres objectifs
[Musique]
en fait il y a une alliance difficile
entre les gobelins et les sorciers noirs
vous avez dit que vous pouviez atteindre l'enfant quand
ils viendraient à pré-au-lard mais tout ce dont vous aviez
besoin était une distraction je vous ai donné une
distraction je viens  a regardé un étudiant
éliminer votre distraction
qui est cet enfant que vous ne me dites pas
mais peut-être que vous ne devriez pas
vous impliquer dans cette
réparation
[Musique] les
ennemis possèdent des capacités défensives et
offensives uniques, y compris des
malédictions explosives des sorts étourdissants des
armes enchantées et plus encore pendant  certains peuvent attaquer
directement d'autres peuvent vous enchanter et
vous neutraliser la
maîtrise du charme de bouclier vous permet
de dévier les sorts à distance et  ct
arme frappe
[Musique]
contre-attaque avec de puissants
charmes étourdissants vous permettant de suivre avec
des combinaisons de sorts étendues
[Musique] les
étudiants qui deviennent particulièrement habiles
à lancer des sorts trouveront de nombreuses façons d'
exploiter la faiblesse de leurs ennemis
[Musique]
slam avec rôti descendant
avec  incendio
dévaster vos ennemis en utilisant diverses
finitions,
vous pouvez même utiliser la puissante magie mystérieuse que
vos professeurs ne comprennent pas
pour anéantir vos ennemis les plus puissants
mélanger et assortir des dizaines de sorts
vous permettra de définir votre style de combat
sur votre chemin pour devenir le duelliste ultime
[Musique]
peut-être  vous seriez assez bon pour vous
faire exploser pendant votre temps
libre en plus des classes et des sorts, vous aurez accès à un ensemble complet de
talents et de compétences de mise à niveau pour vous aider à
progresser en tant que
sorcier relever des défis à travers le monde
pour gagner  expérience
améliorez vos capacités en choisissant des talents pour améliorer
vos sorts plantes et potions pour
augmenter leur pouvoir deci  de quels
talents correspondent le mieux à votre style de jeu pour
vous permettre de vous concentrer sur vos
types de magie préférés,
vous pouvez également acheter ou fabriquer votre propre
équipement magique
qui augmentera vos capacités offensives et
défensives dans l'
équipement de combat peut être amélioré et spécialisé
pour permettre une plus grande  capacités pour votre
style de jeu choisi utilisez un mouvement fort et uniforme
lorsque vous coupez vos idées
[Musique] les
sorts ne sont pas les seuls outils à votre
disposition au combat alors que vous perfectionnez vos
compétences uniques, vous pouvez continuer à poursuivre votre
éducation magique à Poudlard en
progressant votre développement en tant que  une sorcière
ou un sorcier
prépare des potions qui peuvent augmenter votre
puissance lorsque vous avez besoin d'un coup de pouce
[Musique]
cultivez et déployez des plantes magiques pour envahir
le champ de bataille et tenir vos ennemis à
distance,
vous pouvez même libérer des
semis de mandragore mortels pour neutraliser les ennemis sans méfiance
dans la classe des bêtes, vous apprendrez  sur une
variété de bêtes magiques que vous pourriez
rencontrer à l'école et en
explorant le monde entourant le château
et  son objectif d'aujourd'hui est
de vous rappeler à tous comment manœuvrer sur un
balai en toute sécurité
apprendre et maîtriser le vol sur balai est
fortement recommandé afin que vous puissiez
voyager à travers le monde plus rapidement
je veux que vous fassiez mes devoirs d'herboristerie
vous êtes méprisable
[  Musique]
certaines capacités peuvent vous être enseignées par des
élèves qui deviennent vos amis au
fur et à mesure que vous développez des relations avec ces
camarades de classe, ils peuvent vous accompagner dans
votre voyage en tant que compagnons
et au fil du temps, vous apprendrez leurs histoires
est une aventurière courageuse motivée par la
justice qu'elle  cherche
poppy sweeting a un cœur bon et
aime les bêtes magiques se connectant avec
elles plus facilement qu'avec les humains, mais
ce qui se passe maintenant sans peur de la détention
ou de la violation des règles qui fuient à nouveau dans la
section restreinte est à nouveau sebastian
sallo un serpentard charismatique que nous avons
dépassé ce garçon
ne peut pas  inverser une malédiction avec un
secret de famille troublant rien ne peut plus tôt vous
accepterez cette réalité mieux vous
rencontrerez ces étudiants et mo  re pendant que vous
explorez les couloirs des salles communes entre les
classes et les zones de rassemblement régulières,
bienvenue dans la salle sur
demande [Musique] l'un des secrets les plus remarquables de Poudlard est connu comme la salle sur demande
,
vous êtes présenté à cet espace qui
semble ressentir ce que vous  besoin et ensuite vous le
fournit
puisque vous avez besoin de rattraper vos pairs
la pièce vous offre un espace pour coudre
et récolter des plantes brasser des potions et
améliorer votre équipement
[Musique]
un elfe de maison utile nommé deke vous aide à
découvrir les variantes qui vous permettent  pour
nourrir votre propre ménagerie de
bêtes magiques qu'est-ce que c'est,
Dick n'est pas sûr
qu'une seule façon de découvrir que vous pouvez librement
personnaliser cet espace pour refléter votre
personnalité et vos spécialités magiques
[Musique
] tout ce dont vous avez besoin pour votre voyage
n'est pas disponible à Poudlard vous  Vous voudrez
visiter le village sorcier voisin de Pré-au-
Lard, où de nombreux magasins et
vendeurs peuvent vous fournir les
fournitures dont vous avez besoin,
des ingrédients de potion et des recettes
aux s  a besoin de plantes magiques pour toutes sortes
d'équipements
[Musique]
mais pré-au-lard a aussi son
côté dangereux une bande de sorcières et de sorciers noirs
enhardis par l'agitation de l'époque
erre dans la périphérie du village,
vous devez les éviter ou les vaincre pendant
que vous explorez vous  trouver le monde
entourant Poudlard est vivant avec des
merveilles d'activité et des zones d'intérêt inhabituel au fur et à mesure
que l'année scolaire progresse des
saisons et des climats dynamiques rempliront le ciel
d'éclairs ou de soleil ou recouvriront le
sol de neige ou de pluie
des hameaux sorciers uniques parsèment la
campagne
chacun avec des vendeurs et  les résidents qui ont des
histoires à raconter
et des missions pour lesquelles ils pourraient utiliser
votre aide
soyez à l'affût des puzzles magiques enchanteurs
qui pourraient très bien avoir été
conçus par merlin lui
-même lorsqu'il était étudiant à poudlard
des bêtes magiques parcourent les terres à
l'extérieur des murs du château certains  ont été
corrompus par une mystérieuse magie noire
tandis que d'autres risquent les braconniers et
leurs pièges si vous vous sentez  bienveillant,
vous pouvez les sauver et les restaurer
dans la salle sur demande,
mais il existe des dangers au-delà de votre
compréhension dans le monde, de même que les
donjons et les coffres recèlent des
menaces périlleuses et également des récompenses indicibles,
soyez prudent lorsque vous choisissez d'explorer
car cela peut vous conduire vers le bas  un chemin plus sombre
maîtriser les sorts se
lier d'amitié avec de nouveaux alliés voyager à travers un
paysage jamais vu auparavant découvrir d'
anciens secrets combattre des menaces mystiques
apprendre des mystères oubliés depuis longtemps devenir
la sorcière ou le sorcier que vous voulez être
en laissant votre marque unique sur le
monde sorcier
ici
dans l'héritage de Poudlard
[Musique  ]
vous